how's it goin everyone it's Warren and
we have an official update from Marvel
the president of Marvel Studios Kevin
Feige has come out and told us why
samuel l.jackson znik theory has never
called Captain Marvel in the past it's a
question that a lot of people have
wondered ever since we saw the
post-credits scene for avengers endgame
and people are really asking that
question now especially since Captain
Marvel is out and we've seen how
powerful she is a lot of people have
been saying that this is a really big
plot hole in the MCU since Captain
Marvel is that powerful
why hasn't Nick Fury ever called her
before why not in the first Avengers
movie during the Battle of New York when
they were fighting Loki and an alien
army why not during age of Ultron when
Ultron was about to destroy the planet
there have been plenty of times where
the earth was threatened so why has Nick
Fury never called in Captain Marvel
before well Kevin Feige has an answer
for us in Captain Marvel it is revealed
how Nick Fury gets this pager to page
Captain Marvel and in a recent interview
when Kevin Feige was asked why Nick Fury
has never called Captain Marvel before
he responded by saying well I'd say two
things one she does say it's got to be a
real emergency right the other thing I'd
say is how do you know he never hid it
how do we know he never pushed it before
we've never seen him push it before that
doesn't mean he never did the first part
of what Kevin Feige is saying here is
pretty self-explanatory
the pager is only supposed to be for
emergencies he's only supposed to call
her unless it's a true emergency and in
the Captain Marvel prelude comic we
learned that he is relying on the
Avengers Captain Marvel is his last
resort so that's why we've never seen
her in an Avengers film because the
Avengers are Nick Fury's plan a they are
the first offense Captain Marvel is his
plan B his back-up plan in case plan a
doesn't work but then Feige says that
maybe he did call her maybe he did and
we just never saw it on-screen people
sometimes forget that just because
something didn't happen on screen
doesn't mean that it didn't happen in
the MCU
so maybe Captain Marvel has returned to
earth many times between 1995 and
Avenger
and game this may not be the first time
that she's been back to Earth since
Captain Marvel maybe she actually has
helped theory in the past and maybe she
could possibly know who some of the
Avengers are after all over 20 years
have passed since 1995 and Avengers in
game it's quite possible that she has
been in contact with fury in that time
this is something that we could hear
about in Avengers endgame when Captain
Marvel meets the rest of the Avengers
they're definitely going to ask where
she's been this whole entire time maybe
we'll find out that she has actually
been back to Earth a few times to help
fury maybe she's even saved earth a few
more times if this is so it will
definitely come into play in avengers
endgame because she's going to have to
tell the Avengers who she is and how she
knows fury and since Carol Danvers was
not on earth during the snap maybe she
can tell the Avengers about what's
happening in other galaxies after the
snap we do know that Nick Fury was
obviously anticipating a true emergency
in the post-credits scene of Avengers in
game because he had the pager on him but
maybe he had the pager on him because
he's had to call her in the past it
looks like we'll have to wait until
avengers endgame to find out but what do
you all think do you think Nick Fury has
used the pager to call in Captain Marvel
in the past before or do you think that
this is Kevin Feige Gea's attempt at
misdirecting us let me know what you
think in the comments down below and
don't forget about my giveaway I'm
giving away five imax tickets if you'd
like to enter for your chance to win
them all you have to do is be subscribed
to my channel like this video and
comment down below with your thoughts
and your favorite superhero or villain
as always thank you all so much for
watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]